it's a good first date I like anything
where you are not sitting kind of facing
each other if you're gonna go to a
restaurant on a date sit at the bar it's
a much better thing that going to a
table is awkward sitting across from
each other and you're staring at each
other the whole time go sit at the bar
because then you can you can chat with
the bartender you can turn and say
something but you don't have to position
your entire body towards someone what it
allows to happen is a more natural kind
of Attraction and seduction it kind of
we start facing away from each other
become aware of each other like a sort
of side eye I'm aware of you and then
eventually we turn into each other
you've already got the we know each
other part unless you're just
approaching someone out there in the
world a date where you can start pointed
at something and the more Rapport you
build and the more comfort you build you
kind of end up turning inwards that's a
pretty good date walking is a good date